I love cities and when I came to New
York I was like I came home to a place
I've never been
I really just always loved that exciting
energy and to me that's just been a love
of money
this isn't like a series of buildings
Hudson Yards it's really creating a kind
of a lifestyle that people want and
doesn't exist everywhere so it was
really trying to bring the best of what
everybody really in their mind loves
about New York and make it all happen
there and so creating is live-work-play
apartment it's like a city within a city
but still connected to the city so you
don't feel that you're not in New York
it's New York as you want it to be why
did you want to build a Hudson Yards
where every city has to grow nobody
wants to displace people there was no
land to grow in Manhattan except putting
a platform over the train track what was
interesting was that really turned us
onto the whole project was the fact that
the city in the state we're spending
over four billion dollars right around
that area that's what attracted me
initially when you see that type of
capital expenditures to extend the
subway to build the High Line to
renovate Javits Center and build putz
River Park all that money were right in
the center of that that's telling me
something when I saw that that's what
really intrigued me to New York and
that's why I believe in New York and
took on the job even in the toughest of
times and you look back at it I bet on
New York people always want to write it
off but it's too great a city there's
too many great people here and tell many
great things happen here to ever write
off the city
have visions in your mind of your
looking your plans and your selecting
materials yeah you see yeah that's gonna
be great but then when you see the
execution of it it's exceeded even my
expectations so I really believe that
once people get here and they see it's
opened the reactions will be totally
different than just looking at a
building and that's how I think why we
could outperform this market and why
it'd be successful and why we will be
building the second phase sooner than
later
[Music]
you